hello everyone and welcome back to some
daily rapid action unleashes I lost the
last two games so now I will try my best
not to lose a third one and I finally
got some sleep not too much but I think
just right I'm I'm right in the
goldiluxe zone of the needed sleep to
play a decent chess game so let's see
how it goes in this one last game uh
yeah sort of a uh first I played a game
where I played too slow and then I
couldn't uh I I really haven't didn't
have enough time to finish the game the
next one I played much faster uh but
then my position wasn't all that
impressive so now like I said we need to
find that gold Deluxe zone of Chess uh
so let's see if we can do it in this one
and uh yeah we'll see we'll see what we
get we get the black pieces let me just
fix that and our opponent goes for E4
okay we are continuing with our hyper
accelerated Dragon someone Bishop C4
okay you can uh I guess we are
abandoning the idea of going after the
hyper accelerated dragon as obviously
people yeah let's go Knight
F6 go Knight
F6 simply because it comes with a threat
now let's go E6 uh sorry we are playing
against running thoughts we are playing
playing against running thoughts
uh yeah I guess we go Bishop B7 first or
do we go D5 first uh we have to play it
it's best always to play forcing moves
so let's go with with want to D5 and
it's kind of a thing that uh you know if
you get to play C5 in the Cilan you
should be okay although this can no
longer uh be really considered a
sicilian or it can I I really don't know
let's go let's go this let's go Knight
B7 and he will capture with the bishop
okay I really don't mind
that all he's going to put the knights
to E5 and we will we will put the Knight
to the the bishop to C6
so yeah we'll
see this is probably some sort of a
system that is playing that's not uh not
maybe the absolute best but it is okay
so he plays E5 yeah that's
also also very
nice okay so he hinders our development
a little bit but
uh I'm not really buying it I'm I'm not
buying
it yeah it's it's nice but uh okay go
Bishop
C6 can even Castle Queen side if we want
if he castles King side so do we want to
make it a really interesting game huh
that's the
question that's the question do we want
it yes let's do it
let's do
it let's see if we can make it a really
really interesting
game yeah probably something like Knight
to H2 should be perfectly fine for him
but then we get some Knight H6 Knight
the5 maybe G4 later on maybe first H4
and G4 if
possible uh we'll see what it does okay
now he has some F4 ideas uh himself so
we're just going to get our Knight to
H6 no this kind of blunders uh the H5
Pawn sort of blunders the H5
Pawn
H yeah very interesting very interesting
indeed like Queen
A5
with the idea that if he goes F4 we play
what exactly yeah A5 is Queen F5 is nice
but I don't really have a reply to
F4 yeah I do I do F4 G4 we sacrifice a
pawn that's how we get our Knight into
the game we Castle Queen side and uh we
are very happy here
we are very happy
here go
G4 yeah he will take I will take and we
run to the queen side so we're down a
pawn but we've opened up the position
towards this King and that
uh that is not bad he will have F5 but
then that will sort of open up the
position for me as well
uh yeah let's let's run away we run
away F5
now sure can be played can be
played uh still not very still not very
impressed or am I nah no I'm
not all yeah let's
go let's let's go
here
trading yeah he does get the7 for The
Rook
but yeah it is a it is a bit difficult
for me to
develop but I don't think it's uh
impossible as now we might go Knight D7
sort of force a reaction
here yeah capturing I don't think does
all that
much yeah it kind of yeah it really is a
question of how useful the queen is on
A5 but it wasn't really useful on this
diagonal either maybe maybe it would be
okay to play Bishop to G5 with the queen
here but uh
H yeah we'll see if he develops the
bishop maybe I can get some Queen B
before
in I can't really Advance any of my
pawns since he gets this beautiful
Square for his
Knight so yeah that's why he's wasting
time here he has to figure out a way how
to improve his position without giving
me
anything uh which is you know what you
should always do uh yeah okay so he
threatens some discoveries here as he
should saying that my queen is
absolutely useless here so we're just
going to threaten some discoveries here
now this could be very nice if he
doesn't uh stop it yeah he the bishop to
E3 Now sort of doesn't work yeah so I'm
I'm wondering about this move
probably could even be a disaster for
him oh yeah yeah this is not going to
not going to end well for him
or maybe yeah maybe like Bishop D3 this
and then Bishop to F2 but no it doesn't
work because I just capture and then
take the Knight yeah I have no idea what
he plays
here
yeah I don't see it like even if uh he
tries something like check and then
attacks my queen I just push E5 this is
also
winning ah what to do what to do what to
do if you were white here can we flip
the board while playing maybe to get a
better focus I don't think we can yeah
there's no such
option yeah so
okay he's going
uh
ah okay yeah yeah he can just actually
put the Knight on F2 that that
works yeah that actually
works
um does it
work
very skeptical about
this okay so just a pawn push that's how
he's going to do
it
okay okay but now we can take some stuff
yeah some free stuff
here that's the question is it free
though
yeah that's a very elegant Pawn
push
H yeah let's take
here
threaten his Knight a little bit and now
once he moves The Rook uh I might even
go for Queen captur on B2 simply because
if he attacks my
queen if he attacks my queen which looks
dangerous I will play Queen captures on
C2 with sort of an attack on his Rook
why it was very nice to capture on F5
first maybe he will capture on F7 and
now it's uh anyone's G guess it's
anyone's guess what happens
here
okay uh finally we get the Knight into
the
game and now some Rook Rook to G8
followed by Queen G6 if he does nothing
uh the bishop here is quite an excellent
Defender yeah
yeah where when when I was calculating
all of the possibilities I completely uh
I completely disregarded Pawn to D4 when
in fact it's it's the simplest move but
that's uh that's a lot of
fun uh but yeah okay uh Knight cannot
move that's very nice the the bishop can
move but where where do you move like if
he wants to trade down if he tries
something like this to offer a queen
trade I can just go Queen to
G6 uh and then if he like captures here
I can capture with the bishop but the
bishop is defended so also that wouldn't
really make
sense uh he could what else could he do
what's a good move is E6 a move it
really does look like a move but again
what oh yeah so he actually goes for
that wow can't believe
I caught
that uh so what was our
plan plan was very simple Queen G5
yeah yeah Queen G5 okay we are up a
minute so maybe we can invest a few more
seconds into this but I'm not I'm not
seeing
it not a lot of useful squares for the
Knight okay this is a useful square
but sort of to stop Rook G8
eight yeah he might even play that but I
don't know it just
looks yeah not the best but again it
does disconnect my Bishop defending the
knight uh but then I can get my knight
to F5 doesn't do all that much yeah it's
pretty crazy position so what if Knight
F6 we need to find
a uh okay so we just captured The Rook
actually so he decides to sacrifice The
Exchange here
very
nice I'm missing something here H
probably
but or do we take this he takes the
Knight we take the
Knight but we don't have a
threat yeah better just not
complicate maybe some Rook F1 action Al
he's going to trade he just trades
everything all right probably The Rook
is coming to F1 because with the bishop
here uh yeah the bishop is sort of like
a pawn not not all that imp yeah what is
uh what is
this sort of not caring about Queen to
F5 check I am going uh on the on the B
file but yeah not much happening here so
my goal is to get the Knight the the G8
or f8 and win the game so that's my goal
hopefully I'll be able to do it
as I don't see any useful tactics from
him he can't really move the Knight
otherwise check uh check here just wins
The
Rook um yeah so what what else could he
do that's that's the interesting
question yeah last time I was
calculating all the things he could do I
completely missed this uh D4 push so
that was uh quite quite
fun okay so he goes Rook F1 as he should
not caring about this because then this
will be defended but
uh and what if I play this he will just
take with the queen that's his game
plan yeah why not why not but
still still and yeah okay he will have a
pass Pawn so it is possible to play like
this
yeah
H yeah let's go here let's uh ask him to
to do something about this
Knight yeah of course he's going to go
here and now my plan was uh what was my
plan
here my plan here was to stop
checks
okay he can give one
check H yeah he's really making it uh
difficult for me
here
not rush anything stop any checks and we
still keep all of the
threats yeah he goes here as he
should I don't know I I really don't
know about
this
uh very very
strange yeah no
checks okay so he just goes for that
okay
there take
care
okay there like a clean way to end this
yeah we can go like
this
pawns are really doing a fine job
here yeah probably missed a whole lot of
stuff here uh go just go
here he will try maybe to play the Sun
but it would be yeah I mean the knights
are tricky bastards no he's not going to
do it yeah let's just uh okay good game
Mr running thoughts uh from Croatia also
wow who is that maybe I know him
no it doesn't say it just says Croatia
yeah okay uh let's let's check this
out all right so yeah 36 moves really
felt like like more uh so we wanted to
continue uh our adventures of the hyper
accelerated Dragon but our opponent went
for Bishop to C4 right away I played
Knight F6 and uh went for this D5 push
right away which is fine okay I play
Knight B7 sort of Bishop D7 the main
line but still everything is fine
here yeah slightly slightly better for
black uh yeah Queen to H6 first okay uh
yeah this did kind
of make it difficult for me to develop
but I mean still perfectly fine maybe a
bit maybe a bit unorthodox oh G5 right
away G5 right away I went for H5 first
and then G5 but okay at least my plan
was uh was on the uh you know on the
spot I did figure out that maybe yeah
Queen A5 not the best yeah Queen belongs
to D7 although I have no idea why why
would the queen belong on D7 what's the
what's the long-term plan
here oh just being solid Queen D7 you
know if the knight ever moves you maybe
get this diagonal and just castling
Queen side okay so that's also possible
I went Queen A5 uh I thought that I
would be able to wiggle my way in with
the queen somehow even though I was
expecting F4 but yeah this is now z0 so
yeah perfectly equal
position uh yeah and here Queen back to
B6 was the way to go I thought about
this maybe to hinder the development of
the bishop but I actually thought that
opening up the B file would just be
useful for him but since I have this
beautiful setup here with the sort of a
useless Bishop it's a it's a bishop that
has
the uh you know the potential to become
a powerful piece but uh for the moment
is just a pawn a very good defensive
Pawn but still a pawn yeah I went for
this I really wanted my Bishop on G3
sort of to maybe you know in the future
uh it allows for maybe some possible
tactics like if I get my queen here I
can sacrifice The Rook King captures
Queen to H4 check followed by Queen to
H2 Checkmate if the knight ever moves
but uh yeah he went for this bishop move
which is yeah actually very nice yeah F6
obviously better uh and I play Queen to
B6 uh thinking that I was already on the
verge of winning uh and he just played
D4 ah see the reason my brain never
considered D4 is because I was analyzing
it in this position while the pawn was
here so when I played it D4 just became
possible so yeah still very nice yeah
Queen captures on B2 a bit over
optimistic uh he played this I played
this he played this yeah now he's
slightly better plus one for him uh and
uh oh yeah this was the problem yeah
Rook doubling up Rooks immediately
instead of this bishop to E1 move but
it's interesting I was uh uh suggesting
it and he played it yeah Queen G6 now
black is better captures
captures uh and now black is completely
winning but the question is how was my
execution okay yeah the the engine
actually wants this the move I suggested
sort of uh I was I I thought that maybe
this would be a little bit tricky for
some reason yeah King Here and Now what
okay the Knight is hanging but we just
move the Knight now oh then this Knight
hangs okay so you have to play this
obviously but then this Pawn hangs yeah
it's it would be yeah it would be an
Overkill to actually try and play this
so yeah but it's okay still perfectly
winning for me I played yeah Rook to
G3 uh I didn't play Rook to G3 because
after Queen to F5 check I didn't know
the
continuation
like what what was the continuation
let's say plays this okay I saw the
check King F2 oh just that wow yeah okay
I'm blind I'm
blind uh completely blind yeah I went
for this to stop any checks and then I
went for the check uh sort of it's the
same thing I just didn't see it in that
line yeah okay perfectly fine yeah okay
I was just
winning
okay so not terrible uh the the opening
itself We we played nicely basically the
idea was just uh uh as he played
passively against the bishop to C4 move
the idea is always E6 and D5 so that's
what I played uh I didn't want to trade
Bishop so I got the bishop pair uh he
did gra grab more space here in Castle
King but allow I it allowed me to start
advancing my pawns I sacrificed the pawn
for uh for some counter playay and uh
you know it could have gone either way
this game uh it went my way so yeah I
don't know if I was able to find the
goldilock Zone but I was uh I was uh
okay on time I finished with a minute on
the clock which is nice some of you have
been saying that maybe I should use
increment to not run into time trouble
but it it has nothing to do with that I
just like to uh check out all all the
cool lines and I like to check out lines
that sometimes I even know that don't
work but I check it out uh simply
because it might work and I even uh you
know even if I play CL class I sometimes
go into time trouble uh which is you
know weird but okay we won this one
we'll see we'll see how it goes I'm I'm
working hard on improving my hyper
accelerated dragon and some other
openings so we'll see uh we'll see what
we get in the next one uh so yeah once
again hope you enjoyed it uh uh thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon with some more action
unleashes